( intro music )
This isn't a religious war.
It's a war whose roots are based
in poverty, corruption.
Central African Republic
for a time
went psychotic.
( applause )
Peter Gwin:
You know here we have a country
that has 4.5 million people.
It's a little bit smaller
than the state of Texas.
It's 85 percent Christian
or traditional animist beliefs.
And 15 percent identifies
as Muslim.
But here's how the people in the
Central African Republic
identify themselves.
I'm going to refer to the
Central African Republic
by the shorthand that we
sort of all default to CAR,
so if you are confused
that's what I am talking about.
This is a map from
a high school geography book.
And it shows the ethnic groups.
And there are more than 50
ethnic groups and sub-groups.
It's also a nation filled with
treasure literally.
Fairly famous for its diamonds.
One of the biggest diamonds
ever found,
almost 400 carats
was found in the CAR.
It also has gold mines.
Both of these resources are
mined using artisanal methods,
that means it's not
an industrial scale thing.
It's all like open-pit mine,
digging like that.
In recent years,
petroleum has been found
up near the Chad border.
And, there's also
deposits of uranium.
France's first atomic weapon
came from uranium
that was mined in the CAR.
It also has huge reserves of
timber, game animals,
but also the potential
for hydropower.
So what went wrong?
What happened?
Usually this is
the equation for...
for prosperity, right?
You have a fairly
good-sized country,
with a relatively
small population
and all these resources.
So, you know,
why are we where we are today?
And a lot of the answer has to
lie at the feet of these men.
These are the six leaders
of the Central African Republic
since independence.
This is a monument in Bangui.
It was erected in 2008,
which was the 50th anniversary
of independence.
And each person on each
one of these gold busts
betrayed one of the
guys up here.
The guy that takes
the cake of the leaders
in terms of driving
the country into the ground
is this guy,
Jean-Bédel Bokassa.
He was the president for life
and then decided that
wasn't a grand enough title,
so he decided to
become the Emperor
of the Central African Empire.
He was going to rename
the whole country.
He styled himself sort
of the Napoleon of Africa.
And in an era when we saw
Muammar Gaddafi rise,
Idi Amin was in his day,
Mobutu Sese Seko was there,
Bokassa gives them
all a run for their money.
He actually met his nadir when
he decreed that
all school children
had to buy their school
uniforms from his,
a company that he owned.
And when they had...
a rebellion,
when there was a protest,
he had a hundred of
them arrested,
many were beaten, some killed
and that was sort
of the moment that he...
he met his downfall.
Another issue
that's been happening
over the past 10 years or so,
more than that but 10 years is
really the area that we focus on
is poaching the game.
And specifically
the forest elephants.
Poachers have been
coming to the CAR
mostly from Sudan
in organized fashion.
Many of these are Janjaweed.
In fact one man described
it to me
as "it's an ivory bank account".
We just come when
we need money.
In the past ten years,
I think they estimate
5,500 elephants have been killed
for their ivory.
And that's about 62 percent
of the population.
So,
only about 30 percent remain.
The Séléka are a
group of militias
predominantly from the north,
Muslim based.
And funded by Chad to come and
fight the Bozizé government.
They were opposed
by the anti-balaka,
begun as a sort of a local
neighborhood security force.
When the Séléka rose up,
these guys organized,
they realized they needed
some protection.
Once the Séléka were gone
they took out reprisals on
the Muslim population.
They committed many
of the same atrocities
the Séléka had committed.
So that's not the
whole story though.
That's just what's happening in
predominantly the East
and the North of the country.
There's another conflict
that's going on-- far away,
in the far eastern corner
is a little village called Obo.
It's a village of
about 6,000 people.
In Obo,
we don't have the Séléka,
we don't have concerns
about anti-balaka.
These are both Muslim and
Christian children playing.
These children are also under
threat from another place.
And that is,
remember this guy?
Joseph Kony rose to fame
a couple of years ago,
with the Kony 2012 video
that went viral.
For those of you
who don't know the story,
he is a Ugandan warlord
who for the better part
of the last two decades
has been kidnapping children
to fight in his guerilla army
and he sort of moved from
South Sudan to the DRC,
and now he's found his way
into the
Central African Republic.
And, especially given
the security situation
that we have been
facing in CAR
over the past year or so,
his forces have moved,
you know,
more forcefully into this area.
But what's keeping
the people in Obo
safe for the moment--
is your tax dollars.
This is actually a
Special Forces,
US Special Forces base.
It sits right on the
corner of the village.
And the US has been there
for three years now, actually.
In part providing security
but in large part
training Ugandan troops
and advising them on
tracking Kony and his...
and his group.
So these are the Ugandan
troops that they train.
What's different
apparently about this is
that they are actually getting
jungle war fighting training
before they are sent actually
to track Kony and his men.
And when I talk to people
in the village are they happy
that these guys are here,
they said,
if the United States
and Uganda wasn't here,
Joseph Kony would be
sleeping in Obo tonight.
But I understand human nature,
you want to put some faces,
specific faces on these issues.
So, I want to introduce you to
three people,
so the next time you see
a random CAR news report
or a 500-word AP story perhaps,
you'll think of these
three people. So...
This is Aramis. He is from Obo.
And he was kidnapped
when he was 17 years old
at his grandfather's house.
And taken by the LRA
into the jungle.
He spent five years
as a guerrilla fighter.
He had horrible things
done to him.
And he did horrible things.
But he escaped about a year ago.
And now he works with
the US and Ugandans
to broadcast radio messages
into the jungle.
And basically they are trying to
encourage the fighthers
to give themselves up,
just like Aramis did.
And that's been a pretty
successful strategy.
But so, once a week Aramis goes
into the radio station
and basically talks to
his former comrades.
And I sat in on
one of the sessions.
And you know,
he calls them by name,
he tells them, you know, your...
you know,
your family wants you home.
There's amnesty for anybody.
The guys that they are really,
basically going after
these days are Kony
and the other leaders.
Another guy that I'd like you
to meet is Albert.
So, Albert I met on a trip
this summer to Bangui.
I'd barely gotten, you know,
into the city and he was
knocking on my door wanting to
sell me something, you know.
He kept saying,
"I want you to buy
these pictures.
I've got these great pictures."
And I was looking
at the pictures,
like picture of a chicken,
you know,
"Man, do I really want
a chicken picture?
( audience laughing )
And you know, I am sitting there
looking at this thing
and then I realized
it's made out of
butterfly wings.
And I was blown away.
So, he took me
back to his workshop
and he showed me
how he does these.
He collects these
butterflies meticulously
and makes these
stained glass images of life
in the Central African Republic.
Boy climbing a tree.
And this picture has
special significance
because it's his sister.
And she was killed by
the Séléka early this Spring.
Lastly, I want to
introduce you to the
National Ballet of the
Central African Republic.
They perform ethnic dances,
so there's dancers
from all those
ethnic communities
that I showed you.
They are missing 14 of
their members since the violence
and their rehearsal space
has been completely destroyed.
So, they perform--
They perform in a vacant lot
in downtown Bangui.
And people just come and watch,
it's like free performances.
And I happened to come
by one day
when they were performing
this piece,
which is actually a pygmy dance.
And it tells the
story of two women
who are rivals for
the affections of a man.
And one of the women
poisons her rival,
and so an old healer is
brought in
to raise this woman
from the dead.
And this is the scene
that you are going to see.
( singing in Sangho )
( ethnic music )
So, now I'm going to
pass it over to Marcus.
( applause )
Marcus Bleasdale:
Thanks, Peter, for that.
I think it's really
important to highlight
very early on in this
evening that
this isn't a religious war.
It's a war
whose roots are based
fundamentally in poverty.
It's based in corruption.
It's based in mismanagement,
bad leadership,
many of which, you know,
the leaders we were introduced
to through Peter tonight.
And... religion has been used by
the perpetrators to draw lines,
to draw allegiances and
to try to create power.
So, I think we should try to
rise above that this evening,
and try to think in
a much more complex way
about what is driving
this conflict.
What I'd like to do is
to introduce you
to the chronology
of the conflict.
It started as we were
introduced to earlier on that
the Séléka were funded by
Idriss Deby, Chad
to come in and destabilize
the Central African Republic,
maybe take resources,
send those back to Chad
but also destabilize the
Central African Republic,
for the benefit of
its neighbors.
And so this Séléka
group that was--
that came into the country...
attacked the then government,
took power
from the government and...
and then started to
rule over the population
in a very authoritarian way.
And the people who suffered
most under that very
early Séléka rule
were the Christians.
They were the ones that
were forced out of their homes
because they were
persecuted by the rebels,
that were working
in different zones.
And many of these Sélékas
have gone kinda AWOL.
They were funded to an
extent by external powers,
they were funded to
an extent by their leaders,
but they were also
working for themselves.
They were also trying to fund
their own lives and their own,
their own personal
wealth gathering
through looting,
through killing,
through amassing wealth,
through stealing property.
And that insecurity
of these Séléka coming
into the regions
where predominantly Christian
populations were living
led the Christian population
to flee into the bush.
So, I'd like you to try to
kind of put yourself
into that context
when I show you the next
series of images because
essentially these,
the next series of images
I'm going to try and
put you into that
early stages as
the Séléka is ruling
and the Christian population has
been persecuted and are fleeing.
This is an image in a compound,
in a town called Bossangoa.
It was taken in December 2013,
and this is a mother
trying to protect her child
from the gun fire and the RPG's
that are flying all around
this compound as the
Muslim Séléka
are coming in to attack
the town of Bossangoa,
where there are about
10,000 Muslim refugees
staying in the local
school and about
30,000 Christians displaced
staying in the church.
This is a young girl
who was injured in a fighting
as she tried to
flee to the FOMAC base,
which is where
now I am living with
about 5,000 displaced people.
The fight is going on outside
the walls of this compound
And where they are protected by
a small group of
Congolese soldiers.
This image was taken very early
in the morning about 5 o'clock,
just as the sun
is starting to rise.
And normally about the
time when,
if a town is going to
be attacked, it is attacked.
And this is the time when the
Séléka were coming in Bossangoa
and the local population had
amassed around the FOMAC base
because they could feel it,
they could hear it,
they could...
villages like this,
small as they are,
start to feel that there is
something wrong quite early.
And so this population is
kinda waiting at the
FOMAC base to flee,
so that they can get sanctuary.
And this is in the
local hospital
that was being run
by Doctors Without Borders,
Médecins Sans Frontières.
And ironically,
here we have on right side
an anti-balaka fighter and his
wife and child in the middle,
and on the left side
is a Séléka fighter.
Both sitting, lying side-by-side
receiving the same medical
care from the same doctor.
And living in perfect harmony as
they had done before the battle.
As their populations had done
for many generations before.
And children have played
a large part in this conflict
and this young Séléka fighter
was actually brought from Sudan.
So he is Sudanese,
came through Chad and
is now fighting in
Central African Republic
for the Séléka.
And he is about 14 years old .
Very few people really
know their age
but very clearly he is underage.
And both sides
were using children,
and still are using
children in the fight.
We talk about Muslim
and we talk about anti-balaka
and the Christian
and the animists population
but also there are
kind of cultural
group called the "Peul",
who are the nomadic herders,
the people that look after
the cattle
and they have enormous wealth
all embedded in cattle.
And they wander through
this whole region
they wander through Cameroon,
Chad, Central African Republic
and they follow the
rains as the rains move,
they move their cattle
and the cattle graze
and they move through
this whole region.
They don't consider themselves
from Central African Republic
or Chad or Cameroon,
they are from their region.
And they were hugely
persecuted by the anti-balaka
during this time because
they were the source of beef.
They were also
pre-dominantly Muslim
and so they were focused...
the anti-balaka focused
on them for that as well and
this young woman saw her whole
family massacred around her,
her 12 children and
her husband were killed
and she was shot
in the back of the head
and was left for dead
and she was only found
by a group of Peul herders
about five or six days later.
And they brought her near dead
to the hospital where she was
cared for and survived.
But she still has the bullet
in the back of her skull.
This is the church in Bossangoa,
the displaced camp for
the Christian population
about 30,000 people
were there...
and are still there actually.
And this is a Peul
lady who lost her husband,
she lost five of her children
and the only reason that she sat
there with her young boy here
was because she dressed
him up as a girl
and was allowed to leave
the village that she was in
because the group of
anti-balaka that she was with,
were not killing the
young girls,
they were just killing boys.
This is inside the church,
the displaced camp
and the young girl in front
you see here sat on the chair,
she is 13 years old.
She sat there with her daughter
and this is another issue
that we have in
Central African Republic.
The concept of child
marriages is prolific.
And we came across it in
every town that we went to,
every displaced
camp that we went to.
For a lot of the time
the anti-balaka were
in these bushes
hiding away like this
and then things changed.
December came around
and the anti-balakas started
organizing themselves
and they became stronger
to try and come and fight
and engaged the Séléka
in a more active way.
And the Séléka were told
you cannot treat your people
with such disdain,
you cannot treat your
people with such hatred
and expect them not
to rebel against you.
And time and time and time again
organizations,
NGOs, human rights organizations
told them this
and they ignored it.
And the anti-balaka,
the Christian population
came out of the bush.
The anit-balaka came
out of the bush, strong,
motivated and very, very angry.
They started to rise up and
attack the local population,
sometimes the local
Muslim population,
sometimes they were
just taking things
to try to enhance their strength
and have their assets.
This of course led to
the local Muslim population
and the Peul population,
the nomads
to flee and to
try to find sanctuary
and here we have Peul population
hiding in a Christian church,
protected by the priest
in that Christian church.
And this town is in Boali.
And many of the priests
in the churches all around
Central African Republic were
really sanctuaries for the
Muslim population.
They opened their doors in order
to protect the Muslim population
from their own
Christian followers.
This rise of the anti-balaka
lead the Muslim population
deciding to relocate.
This is a Muslim man,
what happened when
these enclaves
were created is that the
anti-balaka then started
picking off the Muslims
on the edges.
Firing, throwing grenades,
throwing RPGs,
and slowly this Muslim
population started to be killed.
They were waiting
there in these enclaves
where people were trapped,
they couldn't leave,
they couldn't go anywhere,
they were completely surrounded
by anti-balaka and
there was no way out safely,
no way out.
And the United Nations,
for much as though
they were there to protect
they were also very fearful
at the beginning to...
to contribute and
assist ethnic cleansing.
And so these people were trapped
in these zones and were
being killed on a daily basis.
This young man was
demonstrating against the state
that the Muslims were being
held in,
and was shot by
a French peacekeepers.
And his wife a few minutes later
finding out that her
husband has been killed.
As the Séléka started to leave,
as the rise of the
anti-balaka increased
the Séléka started
to decide to go,
they started to kidnap people
and they started to take them
to help them,
carry the baggage much as the...
we see with the
LRA carrying baggage
to move it out of the country.
Many of the local
population was kidnapped
by the Séléka and to take them
out of country
and this actually is a man
I met on the street about 50
kilometers outside of Bangui
and he'd been kidnapped
by the Séléka.
Spent nine days carrying
baggage with the Séléka
being beaten everyday
to move quicker, move quicker,
you know,
don't stop because we need
to leave this area very quickly
because we are gonna be killed
and he was being beaten
to carry all the baggage,
he managed to escape
with his father
and we found him on the side of
the road emaciated and hungry
and tired and
we put him in our car
and brought him back to Bangui
and this is the moment,
a very privileged
moment that we have
of taking him home
and introducing him
once more to his mother
who thought he'd been killed.
The anti-balaka rise up and
continue to destroy
the Muslim properties
and here we see one
of the main colonels,
Colonel Dieudonné
of the anti-balaka
with his gris-gris
and his grenades,
ready for the fight.
And this is essentially
what happened after that.
The Séléka now left Bangui,
there is no one to protect
the Muslim population
and so the...
for a period of time between
the last week in January perhaps
and the middle of March,
the way I describe it is that
the country
for a time went psychotic.
There was killing
on a scale I've never seen
in 16 years covering
conflict in Africa.
And imagery that I prefer really
not to have in my mind,
but it's important that we
recognize that it has happened,
it's important that we
understand the severity
of this conflict
and also the hatred
that was for a period
present in this area.
This is a young man
being lynched on the streets
he's a porter,
a Christian porter
who's bringing supplies
into a Muslim enclave
so that they could eat.
They would have flour
to cook with
and sugar to use for their tea.
And as he came in and
he was caught by the
Muslim population
he was serving,
and attacked and then beaten
and then chased
through the streets
with machetes and
with bows and arrows.
Thankfully he escaped.
Many, many more didn't.
This young man actually is
Muslim and is disabled
and couldn't communicate
that he was Muslim
and so was beaten up
to the point of almost death
by his fellow Muslims.
These are the reality of what
happened day after day
after day for six weeks
in Bangui.
I think I witnessed
maybe 10 to 15 people
being killed in front
of my camera every day.
The peacekeepers tried their
best to keep the peace but...
simply they couldn't control it,
there weren't enough of them and
the capital Bangui
was completely out of control.
The anti-balaka
throughout the country,
took control of whatever
they could take control of
and preyed on the
remaining Muslims.
They were trapped
in these enclaves
and they were picking
them off one by one.
And so what did that lead to?
Some people called
it ethnic cleansing.
Amnesty international have
called it ethnic cleansing.
What is ethnic cleansing?
Ethnic cleansing is
where a group,
a population are targeted,
very specific
ethnic group are targeted by
an organized group
and it was very difficult
to say at the beginning whether
the anti-balaka were organized?
Whether they were coordinated?
Whether there was
a chain of command?
It's since been proved
and they have admitted that
there is the chain of command
within the anti-balaka.
And so, maybe we can
call it ethnic cleansing.
But really it's irrelevant
what we call it.
Because the effect,
it was really the same.
This is a Chad Special Forces
soldier coming into Bangui
to escort tens of
thousands of people
out of the region on
these trucks.
I stood there for maybe
45 minutes
as truck after truck
after truck loaded up
to the extent that
this one is loaded up,
left Bangui with
Muslims on board.
This is a young
father with a new born
waiting for the trucks
to leave the center of Bangui.
Many of these trucks
were targeted by anti-balaka
on the road and grenades
were thrown into these trucks
from the villages that
they were passing through.
So not everybody
made it through.
And the trip was hours,
days to...
you know,
they were running the gauntlets
of these anti-balaka groups
for days to get
to Cameroon and Chad.
I recently visited most of the
Peul population,
hundreds of thousands
of the people
that are seeking
refuge in Cameroon.
For the first time in
18 months they feel safe.
For the first time in 18 months
they have enough food.
For the first time
in a very long time
they have shelter
over their heads.
Their children go to school
and so it was very
uplifting after such,
after many,
many months of hatred,
many, many months of pain,
many, many months of killing.
I was starting to see
the population that I'd known
10 years ago in Bangui.
I saw the people that were
making the butterflies.
I saw the laughter again.
I saw the children
playing football again.
All guarded by
now the Cameroon military
so that the anti-balaka
don't come across and start
attacking the local population.
The children, some of them go
to school for the first time.
And they now live as
they lived in
Central African Republic
in these camps in CAR.
And the UNHCR,
United Nations High Commissions
for Refugees
is doing actually a really
interesting... a really good job
of integrating the
refugee population
with the local
Cameroonian population
so that... there is very little
animosity between the two.
So they go into
a town and they bore
10 or 15 wells,
they create 10 or 15 wells
for the whole population,
not just for the
refugee population
but for the whole population.
They build schools
for the whole population,
not just for the
refugee population.
So in a way they are
learning their lessons,
they're becoming
better in what they do
and this is a great example.
We were very encouraged by
what we saw there.
There is a lot
of talk about return,
like when can these
people return.
But I asked all of these people
when did they want to return,
if they wanted to return and
no one wanted to return.
No one needed to return.
And this is a really interesting
concept for refugees,
should we force them,
at some point to return?
Should we be really
be working for that end?
And this is a really
interesting question
that we still don't
know the answer to.
Thank you very much
indeed for listening
( applause )
( outro music )